on prime crime you have no idea where
this is
the killing that changed it all it was a
circus it was unlike any other case and
now all sudden your wife's missing
are you
and the developments happening over 15
years later
there is no to my mind justice that has
been for lacey for scott for conor or
for either of the families
[Music]
hi there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
and speaking of cases we now have to get
into one of the most famous criminal
stories this is the one that arguably
defined the whole genre
it's christmas eve 2002 ron gransky
informs police that his pregnant
stepdaughter has disappeared
that missing woman was 27 year old lacey
peterson
her husband was 29 year old fertilizer
salesman scott peterson
this couple from modesto california may
not have been known at the time but they
would soon become household names across
the country
he was playing golf morning 9 30.
after lacey vanished scott sits down
with police
tell me about the warning
8 o'clock probably or so
showered
we were watching her favorite show
martha stewart
the absence on his part that kind of uh
cool cold
dismissive demeanor that he presented
with
he's been married four years yep
four or five
i guess it's five
i didn't make much of the tape
scott was calm in control keep in mind
he never confesses to anything
he gives
his version of events
according to scott unlike what granski
had told police he didn't golf that day
he says it was too cold and instead
decided to go fishing when did you
realize you're gonna go fishing
well that was a morning decision it
seemed too cold to
hopefully call for the club so
you're telling me that it was too cold
to golf but yet you
decided to go fishing
in an open boat in open water out there
in that bay where
arguably is one of the coldest places
and uncomfortable places that you could
possibly be in hopes that you're
actually going to catch something
how long have you stayed in the water
felt like an hour and a half or so
it seemed that lacy didn't know he was
going voting so he would have been
arguably unreachable to his eight and a
half month pregnant wife which seems a
bit odd two he didn't normally go
boating
okay so that way he'd drive home
see a dog out there yeah
and then he'd still have his leash on
were you calling for lacy or oh yeah of
course to me it sounded like a
reasonable story he was out he comes
home his wife's not there he's called
her a couple times but there was nothing
strange or
inculpatory about his story
the search for lacey peterson grabbed
local and national headlines not only
did law enforcement conduct a widespread
investigation but the public became
engrossed in the case and took an active
role in the search as well what's left
is
the flyers
the canvas tomorrow
the media coverage
although scott himself participated in
the investigation and search efforts
many people believed he seemed a bit off
he presented with a lack of grief
he wasn't just missing his
his wife he's missing this unborn child
what concerns me the most is the fact
that your dog came home with a leash on
that bothers me i mean
no question
yeah
that was what everyone was fixated on
all everybody talked about the way he
behaved well he smiled at the vigil he
hugged somebody look at what he's doing
or what he's not doing
no one knew
what scott was like prior to all of this
people react in many many different
ways what concerns me most is doing
anything i can to further progress i
appreciate that and i don't want you to
hold i don't want you to hold it against
me i mean sometimes i hate asking so you
got to do it but i do i really do have
to do it and yet was scott peterson
totally honest with police
as you'll see
not quite
you guys you guys have any problems
marriage problems
more when we return
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
if you're telling me there's no
you have no idea where
this is
it's december 25th 2002
scott peterson is speaking with modesto
detective albronkini about the
disappearance of his pregnant wife lacey
who vanished the day prior he claims he
went out boating returned home and lacy
was gone
yet it's his seemingly indifferent
attitude during this investigation as
well as some odd details in his alibi
that left
do
many
know about what time you left modesto
um
gosh i don't know
scott peterson was holding a secret
though a secret that the world was about
to find out
received december 16th at 5 44 p.m
hey sweetheart
in a stunning revelation a 27 year old
massage therapist named amber frye comes
forward in january 2003 and admits she
was having an affair with scott
anytime you have a scenario
where a wife goes missing the husband is
going to be the first person that police
look at
now add the idea that there's an affair
going on you have a potential motive
you guys have any problems
marriage problems
let's assume scott's completely innocent
and his wife goes missing
if you're scott do you want the world to
know that you're having an affair and
have been lying to your wife and lying
to the woman you're having an affair
with do you not realize that that's
going to make you the prime suspect so
you might want to cover it up
what scott didn't know was that when the
news of lacey's disappearance hit the
headlines fry began to work with police
and recorded her calls with scott
in one of the most shocking moments
while at a vigil for lacey listen to
where scott says he
hey is new year
and my near the eiffel tower new york
celebrations unreal
the recorded calls with her were so
damning it goes into this kind of master
manipulation mode that he's in
his wife is missing his child who is
unborn is missing but yet he wants to
continue on this charade
there's
well that's good i'm glad you guys
decided to go out
scott eventually comes clean to amber
about his missing
i have wife been
traveling during the last couple weeks
why have i lied to you
when i've been traveling
okay
the girl got married too
and then lacie
not only had scott lied about his
marriage to lacey he even told amber he
was a widower
you deserve so much better
yeah and i deserve to understand an
explanation of why you told me you'd
lost your wife and this was the first
holidays you'd spend without her
that was december 9th
you told me this and now all sudden your
wife's missing
there's no question he is lying to amber
fry about his relationship with his wife
there's no question he's lied to her
about a lot of things in regards to
what's going on in his life
with that said there is not a single
moment in any of those calls that he
ever confesses to anything
of course you couldn't tell me the story
about your wife because it hadn't
happened yet and you were hoping to
resolve in january that would be
resolved and you'd have a story to tell
me
do you think i had something to do with
breaking the channel
well let's see how can i believe that
how can i believe that how could i
believe anything for i am not
evil like that
i would hope not i am oh my god
for scott peterson this was only the
start of his problems
in april 2003 the whole case changed
the bodies of lacy and her unborn son
connor are found
days after the gruesome discovery scott
was arrested and he would later be
charged with murder
but why was scott arrested up next we'll
get into the evidence in the case and
what it tells us
it is arguably
one of the most horrific things that
has occurred relative to
a familial event like this
[Music]
even if we continued in a relationship
and the cops could come over
and
arrest you for lacey's murder
how can i be sure this
this will not occur
because i had nothing to do with it
in april 2003 law enforcement did
officially arrest scott peterson for the
murders of his pregnant wife lacy and
their unborn son connor
this came after months of speculation
that scott was the killer especially
since it was revealed he had been
secretly cheating on lacy with a woman
named amber frye
the bodies were found washed up in the
san francisco bay only a few miles from
the berkeley marina a location that was
very problematic for scott when you got
your boat you took off did you go very
far
well i mean
like a mild went north
i just assumed to be a
decent you know shallow area
scott from the very start says that he
was boating on the waters on the day she
goes missing and the bodies are
recovered in that exact location
okay so you fish in 90 minutes about and
when you go back to
go back to the marina
in fact canine dogs tracked lacey scent
to the berkeley marina
yet there was a major issue for
investigators
so the cause of death is undetermined
the level of decomposition that had
occurred first off you're talking about
uh salty to brackish water which is very
harsh on human remains
and we can see evidence of potentially
this postmortem uh feasting that had
taken place it was marine life that did
this when you're missing significant
elements of the body it's really hard to
make that determination
how did conor's little remains wind up
in the condition that they were in he
had certain little injuries on his body
and he also had tape around
his mouth neck
what was the origin of that
not only could authorities not pinpoint
how or even where lacy was killed but no
murder weapon was ever recovered
in fact there was no significant
forensic evidence connecting scott to
the murders
okay so then when you drive home
what would you do when you go in
put my clothes in the washer
okay that one
however authorities did find a few
things a comforter from the peterson
home stained with what appeared to be
small blood spots
was she wrapped in this was this
something that she was laid upon and
then attacked
additionally hairs consistent with laces
were found on a pair of pliers recovered
from scott's boat
i don't think much about the hair on the
pliers and i say this because you know
scott and lisey live together wouldn't
be unusual for lacy's hair scott's hair
to be on lacy to be on scott
a lot of the reason i went was just to
get that boat in the water to see you
know yeah
law enforcement discovered something
else there was evidence that scott had
made five cement anchors but only one
was on his boat
these were purposed i think in this case
to hold her body in place at least long
enough so that her body was so
compromised by
decompositional changes todd may have
had an impact on the final resting place
of both her and conor
coming up
what happens to scott peterson is not
easy to answer
there's a whole entire nation in this
you don't think that they have a right
to know
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the law and crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is long crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
there's no possible way i had anything
to do with this
on june 1st 2004 the trial of scott
peterson began the man accused of
murdering his pregnant wife lacey and
their unborn son connor back in december
2002.
this trial was groundbreaking it was a
circus this was one of probably the
first cases if not maybe the case that i
think triggered this huge interest in
true crime because it was unlike any
other case as far as the attention and
the obsession
and the high emotions involved
the defense had a huge advantage no
confession no witnesses no murder weapon
and no evidence of how or where lacey
was killed peterson's legal team also
had an alternative theory of what
happened which was tied to a burglary
across the street from the peterson home
after she came back from her walk
she came across these burglars
confronted them and they in fact
kidnapped her killed her and dumped her
body
the prosecution was armed with
circumstantial evidence from authorities
discovering the bodies in the very area
where scott had claimed he had gone
boating to when amber frye scott's
mistress the woman he had lied to and
had cheated on lacy with took the stand
this case was nothing until amber fry
walked into that courtroom she was
someone that the jury wanted to hear
from they viewed her as a victim of
scott peterson
they viewed scott in a very different
way once they heard the audios between
amber frye and scott peterson
stand in my shoes and look through my
eyes what is it that i'm supposed to
perceive of all this how many lies
you've told me
i would consider me a complete
who's done something to amber that she
does not deserve
and
question if
you could ever trust me again
after a six-month long trial and days of
deliberations the jury convicted scott
peterson of the murders of lacey and
connor and he was ultimately sentenced
to death
all of this circumstantial evidence came
together
without necessarily the aid of a lot of
forensics
and was powerful enough that it
convinced a jury of his guilt
i still don't think that there was
enough evidence to convict scott
people hated him and for them that was
the evidence of it
the story though is not over
the president of the united states
supreme court and this court of course
say that
the erroneous dismissal of a single
juror
constitutes constitutional error
in 2020 the california supreme court
overturned scott peterson's death
sentence
when the judge was one deering the
jurors the big mistake he made is that
any potential juror who indicated that
they did not believe in the death
sentence were immediately removed as
potential jurors well that's not correct
you have to continue to ask them whether
or not despite their feelings they can
still impose the death penalty he didn't
do that
yet life in prison without the
possibility of parole may not be the
automatic future for scott
at the time of this recording there's a
chance his convictions could be thrown
out too and he may receive a whole new
trial
this all due to the alleged misconduct
of a trial juror
on the questionnaire they were asked if
they'd ever been a victim of a crime and
her answer was no but in reality she'd
been
a victim of a crime not just once but
twice she was in fact pregnant
at the time so she was literally in the
same shoes as lacey peterson
we kept exposing or finding what i
called at the time stealth jurors
meaning jurors who were lying and had an
agenda to get on here
we caught a couple of them in real time
this juror we did not
that this juror
did commit what it appears she did do
then the verdict itself is tainted and
must be thrown out
a new trial for scott peterson would be
interesting especially since scott's
sister-in-law janie peterson has been
adamant that she has new evidence
proving his innocence namely that lacy
was alive when scott left the house
this time around i know the defense is
going to have a chance to show that
there's other suspects involved
additional information about the
timeline people who had seen her walk
if you play it out there's no way they
convict him
there is no to my mind justice that has
been for lacey for scott for conor or
for either of the families every
defendant should have their chance at a
fair trial this is the right time for
him to have that trial
i know that there's still people who
have made up their minds but there's
plenty of people who have not
i am hoping that it's going to happen
soon
you said you've lost your wife no
yeah
how did you lose her then before she was
lost
explain that
you're a different kind of lost amber
then explain
there is
much more evidence to indicate that
peterson
is in fact culprit and that they did get
the right man in this case because it
points back to amber fry he's a
womanizer who didn't care about his
family
he was going to separate himself from
the burden of uh of being married and
and certainly with connor on the way
being a father
when you're working with the arithmetic
in this case and you begin to think
you know who in the world would have had
that level of motivation
uh to take lacey's life i think that
your final answer at the end of the day
is scott peterson
scott peterson you know that is a name
that many thought would never be back in
the news will he get a new trial and
present new evidence
at the time of this taping it's still up
in the air
the question of if scott's the real
killer and what exactly happened to lacy
and connor that is one that continues to
be debated and thought about even after
all these years
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time
be safe
[Music]
you